how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I guess in Donald it is true that Lenin
looked with admiration on the German
post office but he did not look with
admiration on German central planning
with its direction of labor
it's a conscription of trade unions and
labor etc if you want to understand how
that evolved in the Soviet Union and it
was not something that was a model that
they imposed you have to understand it
in the context of the civil war the
invasion of the Soviet Union by the
forces that were victorious in world war
one and it was a unfortunate response to
that civil war and I think as Isaac
deutscher pointed out the great
historian of Stalin the journalist for
The Economist here in Britain of what
happened during the course of the war
was that the anarcho-syndicalist turned
out more popular than the Bolsheviks
when you had competing parties but did
parties were done away with because it
was never thought by socialists that
once workers had been won to socialism
they might no longer support it and they
responded disastrously disastrously by
closing off freedom of expression
competing parties etc were criticised
immediately for this most famously by
Rosa Luxemburg why this is why she's a
hero of the Democratic Socialist Left
not only do you not have Liberty when
you don't have competing parties freedom
Association what especially matters in a
socialist society is workers develop
ordinary people developing the
capacities to govern and you can't do
that where you have bureaucracy closing
that off so yes the crack existed in
Soviet socialism it was resolved by 1924
you're quoting from
Leonard Cohen he's thinking of this
there is a crack in everything let's
ring the bells that still can ring but
he thinks and I think there was also a
crack in social democracy let me just
finish with this what Eagleton says it
is the failure of the present in terms
of in terms of redeeming our
possibilities this is what redeems the
socialist vision and the attempt by us
socialists as Democratic socialists to
find a way for that not to happen again
and it is as opposed to what we just
heard the appalling failure the
appalling failure of neoliberal global
capitalism to realize most people's
potential as we see in the way the gloss
is off of it everywhere the tragedy of
course is that the failure of Soviet
socialism much more importantly the way
in which social democracy the Third Way
Blair ISM all the European Social
Democratic parties embrace neoliberal
globalization leaves them now bereft in
terms of speaking to their own
constituency get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog